acad president tom sherak that's a  pretty good dinner huh yeah well Fang  a lot of people here you're having fun  that's good okay welcome back as many of  you know I'm a baseball fan thank you i  would say i'm a Dodger fan but the  gentleman who has something to do with  the Giants is in the room and one of the  things I really love about our Board of  Governors is that is there like an  all-star team there at the top of their  game their chosen for their  accomplishments and they represent the  best of their craft they also as a  condition of being on the board submit  to random drug testing every six weeks  just kidding although I would be  interested one of the most important and  satisfying things the board does is  select each year who gets the governors  awards so I can think of no better way  to begin our tribute to tonight's first  honorary Oscar winner then by asking  some of our past and present governors  to tell you about this remarkable artist  you